[Music]
I
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet dment giving values contagious
this world are entrepreneurs we get no
value to haters run homie look what I be
come I'm I'm the
one melee Mady all right so Happy
Thanksgiving everybody we uh came in
this morning had no idea Kelly was going
to prepare this entire literally turkey
gravy We Got The Whole Nine going on
here Kelly and we decided last minute to
do podcast today to cover some of the
stories and spend some time with you
before you go out there and spend the
time with your family while Tom makes
that weird noise but uh you mean talking
yeah no it's just Kidd it's the it's the
Tom E your turkey tomm think these these
special effects like he does like he
thinks he it adds to the to the spice he
thinks that well we appreciate you like
you know some people have those buttons
you press with the sound think by the
way this this a new shirt for you it's a
new look for you you look great I got
paid last Friday so I got don't blow all
your money
on so okay all right first of all
whatever you guys do listen if you're
driving Bentley On the Border just slow
down a little bit right like it's
seriously it's don't be Reckless
everybody thought there was a situation
going on with this car we'll talk about
that a little bit Israel Hamas yeah uh
reach hostage release deal in exchange
for 4 day pause and fighting potential
like saying look potential which is not
a good like bargaining like listen we
give us this but we'll think about it
it's going to go right back to bombing
right yeah both sides are just kind of
trying to say well because the other
side is afraid of of us that's that's
why they're agreeing to do this but one
side is saying if we do it we're still
going to come back and kill you but take
four days off and have dinner with your
family we'll come back and revisit this
is like World War I where the uh all the
fighters came out and they played soccer
one day on Christmas and they and they
killed each other got back were you in
that game no no no I was watching I was
not actually Sam Alman Sam Alman returns
to open AI yeah in a bizarre reversal of
Fortunes binance CEO Xiao to plead
guilty uh to federal charges stepping
out I think he's agreeing to pay $50
million this the guy CZ that what
happened
to crypto and NFP and all those guys
musk to donate X advertising Revenue to
hospitals in Israel uh and Gaza uh most
Americans tip 15% or less at a
restaurant and some tip nothing here's a
poll to talk about that 40% of
Americans uh are afraid to walk alone at
night most in decades polls say like
what do they do do they how do they find
this stuff like to find out who's afraid
of walking during the alone at night
maybe we'll see if some of you guys we
can run a poll when we do the podcast
topic we'll get to it and we'll do the
poll gun ownership reaches record high
with uh uh American El electorate us
existing home sales hits more than
13year low prices pushes push higher us
home sales on paay for a wor year since
93 that's 30 years Suzanne sandom dumped
by Hollywood agent UT over anti-jewish
rant John Lovitz tears into coar Kim
Kimmel for pushing political agenda in
late night scar bro you got to see this
video makes doomsday prediction for
Trump's second term talking about he's
going to execute everyone and anyone uh
little random but we'll see what he's
got to say Obama ex National Security
Council adviser miles during per walk
you just have to watch what this guy has
to say very random
weird men may benefit from their looks
in the workplace more than women do
we'll debate that I don't know if that's
true or not watch this Jamie Fox accused
of sexual assault in new lawsuit and you
know who just got accused this morning
Eric mayor Eric Adams accused of
sexually assaulting women in '93 New
York 93 New York 1993 in this where
we're going with this at this point TI
to real estate cuz that's the last time
real estate the 93
1993 so we'll talk about that as well
anyways let's get right into it Tom
let's start off with Sam Alman returns
to open AI which to me the last few days
for Sam Alman if there's if there's been
anything he now knows exactly who his
enemies are who's on his side who to be
careful with who not to get closer to
but here's what happens Sam Alman
reinstated as open AI CEO following a
surprise ouer with the company
announcing we have reached an agreement
in principle for Altman to return to
open AI ask CEO with a new initial board
Brett Taylor a former co-o of Salesforce
will chair the new board alongside Larry
Summers and Adam D'Angelo Altman Express
his enthusiasm saying he looks forward
to building an open AI strong
partnership with Microsoft the company's
primary financial backer their
circumstances surrounding Al alman's rep
removal and reappointment remain
mysterious but T tensions between
alman's push for aggressive AI
development and the original board's
cautious approach played a significant
role Tom wow well Happy Thanksgiving Sam
you're you're back in the chair having
Thanksgiving and uh it was kind of funny
Elon mus put out a tweet on this and it
says guys this was pointless this was
like a you're back where you started
this was an interesting marketing stunt
so who who won who lost Tom who looked
embarrassing uh who looked embarrassing
was uh the board the board looked very
embarrassing they were we now see many
stories out there and the board um had
you know elas sver comes to the board
says you know he's not being honest with
us he's not being forthright blah blah
blah blah we've all read the articles
and then the board looked really clumsy
there was no legal consultation if they
consulted legal they sure didn't have
those lawyers out there to talk to the
media there was no like Crisis
communication group they were using
there was no PR firm and and soon as
this leaked out they also kind of missed
what was the what was the temperature of
the employees cuz 7 00 employees said
I'm with Sam um and so the winner in all
this it is is Microsoft Microsoft has
unbelievable control over open AI yeah
there's going to be this board and
things like this but Microsoft that put
the 13 billion in and Thrive capital and
coasta Ventures they got everybody back
together so the winners were all of
those people that put money into the
funds that were invested by Thrive
Capital like let's say upad had put
money into a fund at Thrive capital and
they they invested in open AI you're
making phone calls when this is going on
say guys did our did my investment just
go up and smoke we I depend on you guys
Thrive Capital who assimilates a fund
and invests it the winner is Microsoft
and the winner are the investors because
the band gets back together and also I
think it's a good thing that Sam and
Greg Brockman are not on the board now
they have a stronger board along with
Larry Summers who comes from a regulated
side the treasury side I think that's
good so I think the winner is I think
Microsoft and it's a good thing to have
open AI with a more structured board is
the fear is the fear that open AI Sam is
so ambitious to accelerate the process
of advancement with AI that we may lose
control and AI may be more powerful than
you know those who are humanists such as
Elon Musk you have summed up in one
sentence what many people said was the
debate going on between half the board
and then Sam and Greg yeah this is kind
of what I was referring to the other day
actually think this is a great thing for
who Humanity all we hear constantly is
that AI is going to take over the world
and that humans are no longer exist and
we're going to be subjugated citizens to
basically AI generated robots that are
be controlling us as overlords I think
in the short term this was obviously not
a good look for open Ai and chat GPT and
Sam and everything but I think as the
dust settles this would be good for all
of us because the one thing that they
did receive from all this is Clarity the
board didn't know where Sam was Sam was
sort of like keeping things close to the
vest not essentially trusting the board
us regular human non-android individuals
are like I don't even know what the
hell's going on these people are about
to take over the world and the planet
and at the very least we have some
clarity on what they're doing now what
their intentions are and they were
bringing on these sort of grown-ups in
the room especially Larry Summers like
Not only was he the uh Secretary of the
Treasury back in the uh what Bush days
Obama days Obama him and Tim gner were
Obama's guys exactly he was Al the
president of Harvard so this is a guy
who has educational background
government background Finance background
and is sort of just sort of a
levelheaded player in all this and I
think at the end of the day the the the
humanist side of things certainly won
how's it what their stock uh price doing
Pat once this all this announced it's
it's a private company it's not oh it's
not they haven't even gone public open
Ai No it's not out there yet they had an
implied valuation 86 86 billion where
independent independent investors is
we're going to buy shares from from
employees willing to sell so that gives
the employees the ability to monetize
their shares after four years of work
investing their are they saying that
they're going to be is there like a date
of when they're going to go public uh
probably at some point I would think Tom
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question what do you what do you fear
with
AI what do you what do you you're a
pretty level-headed guy but at the same
time you can also entertain uh opposing
ideas what do you fear with AI so I fear
with AI the same thing
if you've ever goog Googled the phrase
Market stock market circuit breakers
you'll see that phrase circuit breaker
flips today on XYZ stock so what I fear
is autonomous engines and autonomous
engines is like it's like the same way
people fear self-driving cars it's not
perfect all the time bad things happen
we saw that cruise taxis actually has to
suspend operations after they hit a
person ran into wet concrete ran over
construction barricade
in San Francisco so the word autonomous
is what concerns me and when you see
autonomous trading and see here it is
circuit breakers are temporary measures
that halt trading to curb Panic selling
on stock exchanges the Panic selling is
not people the Panic selling is the
autonomous engines that see a stock
moving and they all follow each other
it's like if you see those big pictures
you know from National Geographic where
all the analou in the serengetti one
Tiger shows up EXC me one lion shows up
and all the an animal or the zebras turn
at the same time it's like beautiful
artwork they run at the same time ladies
and gentlemen that is what program
autonomous trading does on the stock
market something Spooks them and then
there's a circuit breaker where the
stock market says suspend the stock and
what they're really saying is stop all
the program engines so I fear the word
autonomous and engine and AI can allow
more autonomous engines to happen in
things and you got to think about
electric power grids you got to think
about a lot of stuff and so that's the
humanity side that I worry about is when
these engines or things go
autonomous and it doesn't take anybody
to be a PhD to figure this out just look
at the self-driving cars and look at
what autonomous trading does on the
stock market there are times when they
get out of hand and there's got to be
something and the stock market uses
circuit breakers autonomous cars where
their license was pulled and they had to
stop until they do more research that's
what you fear I fear the word autonomous
engines things running a muck have you
watched the movie Movie
Creator Creator just came out have you
seen it no you seen it so I I normally
wouldn't recommend any of these new
movies coming out this is actually very
good movie worth watching it's I think
it's on uh U Apple TV now you can order
it it was in the theater the story about
Creator is it's it's a I'll just Science
Fiction it's it's the creator of AI so
said in 2070 15 years after a nuclear
detonation in LA and a war against AI an
ex Special Forces agent is recruited to
hunt down the kill and kill the Creator
the Creator is you know how our Creator
God the creator of AI he wants to kill
the Creator who has developed a
mysterious weapon with the power to end
the war right
so what levels like how advanced can AI
get you know sometimes you watch these
movies and and they take you places and
then these movies 20 30 years later
become a reality you're like oh yeah
yeah that's normal now it's a regular
Tuesday today you know but how crazy do
you think it gets is it something that
at all even consumes your mind as
somebody that's got two kids yeah it
doesn't consume my mind but I'm very
very aware of it remember the circuit
breakers were made by the stock market
to stop that they have software now that
teachers use to see if a if an if a
paper was written with chat gbt or
something Rob go back to that that was
you see what I mean they put you have to
put a contrasting control
it's like when you make you invent the
accelerator somebody has to invent the
break put it put it that way simple as
that every look at this article Rogers
found go to it go up a little bit this
is 10 things movies from the past got
right about the future okay go down
let's see what these 10 things are okay
uh a trip to Moon 1902 lunar exploration
okay for those of us that believe we
actually went to the moon right Vin
airplane 2 1982 great movie airport body
scanners in the back okay uh Star Trek
the motion picture cell phones all right
that's 79 fair enough Smart House Smart
Homes Smart Home Smart House interesting
Disney the Cable Guy technology
integration great movie okay keep going
keep going hackers VR headsets wow 1995
keep going okay Blade Runner 1982
electric Billboards that was incredible
and and it's now like everywhere keep
going a great movie Total Recall
self-driving cars 1990 33 years later
it's here just far the best movie uh on
this panel so far on this list toal it
may be his best movie well Terminator 2
probably keep going keep going what's
that what's that one okay 2000 Space
Odyssey T tablets and videos video calls
1968 they predicted that Minority Report
targeted ads 02 21 years ago okay and
then that's it okay so to me do you do
you fear it what do you think about I
saw I saw a documentary I want to say 10
years ago called the transcendental man
this guy Hugo Dei g a r i s great
pronunciation I wasn't going to say
Garis uh so Pat this guy was born in
he's an Australian retired researcher in
the subfield of artificial intelligence
and evolved Hardware he became known in
the '90s this is in the '90s bro for
research of the use of genetic
algorithms to evolve artificial neural
networks using three-dimension cellular
automata which uh inside the field
programmable gate arrays by the way he
claims that this approach would enable
the creation of what he terms artificial
brains which would quickly surpass human
levels of intelligence P he's saying
this these things will think a billion
times faster than how we think in in a
in a nanc he's he has a belief this is
him by the way he's 75 76 years old that
there's going to be a major war between
the supporters of opponents of
intelligent machines resulting in
billions of deaths is almost inevitable
before the end of the 21st century He
suggests AI systems May simply eliminate
the human race and humans would be
powerless to stop them because of
technological singularity he's Pat we're
creating things that are going to start
thinking on their own and he said when
you look at an ant Pat do you even think
twice about killing it you don't think
twice we're going to be those ants to
these things because they're going to be
like who who are these people telling us
what to do and then they're going to
take over you believe that I 100%
believe that I think that's the
that's my fear is that that and that's
the documentary you want to you want to
eye Awakening documentary is this
Transcendent man 100% so you're talking
about like Skynet you know T2 Skynet
became self-aware yeah what once it
start and by the way there by the way I
do that's that's the one thing like if
you think about with AI it is when it
becomes self-aware and it can realize
how powerful it is there was a cartoon
also they did a couple years ago autom
full autonomy yeah cartoon they did a
couple years ago when the AI realizes
how powerful it is and it's game over
and Pat think about it remember Rob
there was there was Pat which company
started doing the sayi thing and it was
no filter they started asking it
questions like what do you want to do
and you know what it said I want to kill
everybody I want to do nuclear war and I
want I want to be in charge there's no
Goda it's like and then they shut down
the system it's like we're playing with
something that's very very dangerous and
by you and I think you said this Pat um
what's it called when when it's it's
like IIA is help everything's helping us
it's really easy for us to use it but we
don't realize that this thing one day is
going to creep up and it's going to take
over there was an AI researcher at
Google and Rob you can um search this
who was like a whistleblower he was
later semi discredited remember this
where he said that they' done
experiments and the um and the AI
demonstrated you know kind of an
emotional response or a um and he was
later he was later
fired was that him yeah Pat you don't
think so you don't think that one day
this thing the these things that
especially if it's going to think on its
own and it's thinking a billion times I
think Brandon told us something about
this Quantum Computing this thing is
going to own you and you're not it's not
going to want to Google fires Blake Lon
the engineer who claimed AI chatbot as a
person oh God I mean it's well I'll give
you a little so ever since the first
Industrial Revolution right what was the
Advent of the steam engine right we're
now approaching what the fifth
Industrial reolution what's the
Industrial Revolution basically
replacing human jobs whether it's uh you
know pushing stuff building stuff
slamming stuff just
masonry um to basically utilize What
machines do now it's so the first
Industrial Revolution was what the steam
engine and then it went into mass
production like factories everything
with that then the third Industrial
Revolution was you know Digital internet
everything that we've known as far as
growing up in the ' 80s and the 90s the
fourth Industrial Revolution which we're
sort of in the process of right now was
everything with blockchain and
technology and cell phones and
everything like internet 2.0 or 3.0 or
web 3 that you hear about and the the
fifth one is that is essentially what
we're talking about here is where
basically humans and machines become one
oh God and it's it's scary and that's
why going back to the initial premise of
this conversation is like everything
that happened with open AI this week I
think is a good thing for what Humanity
because if this thing progresses to the
point where like we have no clue let's
face it like we're some pretty decently
smart guys whatever we get it we have no
clue what they're building out there and
Silicon Valley and chat gbt and open a I
have no clue how this [__] works most
people don't and there's a lot of fear
Vinnie especially where like I don't
know what's going on Elon Musk and
neuralink and the brains and the
satellite and the start link it's so
much stuff going on there and this pause
I think is a good thing neuralink I I
found one tweet from a person that
represented themselves hey I've worked
in Las Vegas security for a while and
ner you would not believe the phds that
are being hired in Las Vegas because
they don't want a neuralink equipped
person to come in and the the game they
fear is blackjack right they don't oh
damn right they don't want someone with
a nerve in the movie The Hangover when
when our buddy went there just counting
cards like Rainman yeah that's exactly
right and so there so the people the
people with something to lose are
already trying you know say the guy that
invents the accelerator he made a lot of
money for the guy that invented the
break right yeah exactly so and so
supposedly there are phds that are
research level in Las Vegas that have
been hired by the casinos to consider
all of these things that are coming
everything from Google Glass cuz you
can't remember the square Google Glass
and they if you were in the casino with
them they would like walk right up to
you and say excuse me you need to put
those in your pocket take those off
always bet on black Tom no but that's
interesting the people with the most to
lose are usually the first people to the
podium follow Vegas follow the money to
put the breaks on something let's look
to the next story and by the way the guy
with uh neuralink uh musk to donate X
advertising Revenue to hospitals in
Israel and Gaza and this story is going
to lead into a couple different things
Rob I'm going to text you a couple
things can you go up to Mark Cuban's
tweet at musk about what he says with
chichan Chong you'll see it if you go to
it go to the he also gets the ad yeah so
so if you if you I'll read the story
first and then we'll go to that so uh
musk pledged to donate all advertising
and subscription Revenue linked to the
Gaza conflict on his platform formerly
Twitter to hospitals in Israel and the
Red Cross in Gaza he stressed the
importance of caring for innocent lives
regardless of their background stating
we should care about the innocent
regardless of race Creed religion or
anything else this announcement follows
musk's previous controversy where he
faced allegations of promoting
anti-Semitism semitism for his response
to a racist post with the comment you
have said actual truth The Exchange
occurred in response to a criticism of
foundation to combat anti-Semitism
campaign video so that that's said here
then Mark tweets this out if you can
zoom in a little bit if advertisers were
getting results for their X ads or
possibly if you posted data that showed
the ad
on this platform were effective and
produce results you would be in an
entirely different position if your ads
produce results businesses would tell
you they understand how difficult it is
to completely eliminate hate on the
platform if they don't produce result
there is no reason for a big company to
[__] around and find out that their ads
showed up next to a hateful post I can't
tell you how many times I got chich or
is a Chun ads for CBD gummies [__] I
would never buy on the on other platform
ads sometimes are early relevant to my
interest keep going up that never occurs
on this platform agree or disagree
that's the real world today okay so now
then I see this here which I want to
kind of share with you
is what just came out Rob I'm going to
try to send this to you to to show do I
go Robert's uh MacBook or Rob's iPhone
do you go by Rob or Robert which one is
it Rob iPhone okay I sent it to both of
them so great addition Rob so if if you
pull this up this is a this is something
that started going around yesterday and
everybody was showing it to say hey
here's the data here's what we're
looking like this the kind of results
we're putting in Twitter and Tom I want
to get your thoughts on this because you
know they're trying to say look traffic
driven to a domain via Google's top 100
organic search results again Google so
this isn't anybody else number one is X
weird Twitter then it's Instagram then
it's Facebook which means hey we're
getting more eyeballs to the ads you're
running than Instagram and Facebook when
you see this this gives credibility to
musk to say we are up so now it's very
easy for us who are not in it to see the
data to say well may Man X is getting
destroyed bro you're seeing what's going
on all the racist stuff that's going on
on Twitter and that's become a racist
infested you know platform you know
nobody wants to advertise there okay are
they not
advertising because of the com the ibms
of the world and the companies we read
about the Coca-Cola is taking a break
whatever the list of companies we talked
about last Tuesday Rob if you can pull
pull up the company so I say the right
names and and don't want to get that
wrong which company stopped advertising
on X so are they stopping it because of
what's you know available and freedom of
speech is risky or are they stopping it
because they're not getting return on
their money I miss one of them there you
go Apple Disney IBM NBC Universal
Paramount Fox Sports parison brother
discovery transparent company okay so uh
what do you think Tom do you think
there's credibility on what Mark cubin
is saying and do you think there's
credibility in that data showing that
there's more eyeballs on Twitter than
the other two platforms well first of
all I assume there's credibility in the
data and so the data is pretty clear
that the Google search is significantly
you know directing to X number one
number two Mark cubin doesn't protect
present any data but he presents a very
informed logical argument I agree but
he's not putting very informed by the
way we talked about chichin Chong CBDs
two podcasts agos that you and I are
getting these ads and we're saying what
the hell is this why is this so either
the ad buyer for chichin Chong they're
high and they're just putting ads
everywhere which is also logical very
probable but what I look at here is that
I see something and I'm going to be like
Mark cubin I'm going to be logical I see
something in this list Apple Disney IBM
and Main stream media just call it that
mainstream media Al together there look
at those I don't see Levis I don't see
Coca-Cola I don't see a lot of consumer
products by the way Apple woke Disney
woke IBM definitely woke NBC mainstream
media woke woke woke woke woke that's
what IBM you would
put IBM I see people that didn't like
mus in the first place okay go pull up
their Dei score that's all you got to do
look at IBM ESG you doing that is that
actually how you would Define woke just
the Dei score if no if they are yeah
right there if that is I mean let me
look let me think no I'm actually asking
a question like how would the way you
want to judge a company is if they're
like for example you know you know what
is the only team in the in in Major
League Baseball that didn't do Pride
night yeah it was uh Texas Texas Rangers
yeah exactly W the World Series Texas
Rangers Texas Rangers won the Super Bowl
that's right they wanted love that Super
Bowl team so the the G so guess what
every body was saying all the other
teams are all ESG Dei except for the
Rangers there was credibility in a
company that didn't have a pride night
so IBM has it as well so Tom you were
saying keep going so so I'm going to be
I'm going to be logical with this
everybody that jumped on the band Wigan
they didn't like Elon Musk in the first
place it's almost like they're waiting
for him to do something aha there you go
again but it's also a very very
sensitive time because let's talk about
the topic the topic is Israel Hamas and
there is horrifying things going on so
we're not just talking about do you
believe George Floyd or do you not and
the man died in that that encounter it
it's not something like that this is a
major people are saying two-sided
genocide that's going on at that Elon
Musk weighed in on but these people that
didn't care for Elon Musk in the first
place quickly jumped on his head yeah if
you recall there was an interview what
was that 6 months ago I think it was a
BBC journalist that he sat down and did
a one-on-one with musk do you remember
that like the woman don't care that no
no not that one not that one that was uh
that was a CNBC interview it was a guy
that basically was like so uh ever since
you've been you know coming on the
platform everyone says that you platform
was way more racist show me example and
he's like yeah just show it to me show
me show what they said show but they
said who said that no but I yeah it's
like so you're talking about basically
emotions versus logic or data so I don't
know if you have it it's not that yeah
this one right here the guy yeah that
one can you play that I love this I love
you don't like or or hateful what do you
mean to describe a hateful thing yeah I
mean you know just content that solicit
a reaction something that may
include slightly racist or slightly
sexist those kinds of those kinds of
things so you think if something is
slightly sexist it should be vent I no
you're saying I'm not saying anything
I'm say I'm trying to understand what
you mean by hateful content and I'm
asking for specific examples um little
too first of all and you just said that
if something is guy in the right mind
sits with one of the smartest if not the
smartest guy in the world would I being
ready with freaking proof and facts who
the hell are you bro Pat he has an
iPhone watch the end of this yeah and by
the way P his notes are on his iPhone SE
I've seen this so many times I watch the
whole interview go well me you've asked
me whether my feed starts basically
tripping over own wants answers look
that's why I'm asking for examples yeah
let's go can you name one example I I
honestly don't honestly you can't name a
single example I'll tell you why CU I
don't actually use that for you feed
anymore because I just don't
particularly like it a lot of people a
lot of people are quite similar I only
only lookang on you said you've seen
more hateful content but you can't name
a single example not even one I'm not
sure I've used that feed for the last
feed three or four weeks and I see the
hateful cont content because I've been
I've been using I've been using twister
since you've taken over for the last six
months okay so then you must have at
some point seen that you for you hateful
content I'm asking for one example right
you can't give a single one and I'm
saying then I I say so that you don't
know what you're talking
about you see how he did it so
eloquently just give me the data Give me
the give me the facts well this is what
that's the video talking but see this is
how this is exactly how the left
operates it's like no no you're this
you're this you're that but then when
you check them and you say show me the
proof they go no well I heard it from
yeah yeah cuz it's all [__] the
proofs and the pudding would you pass
some of the pudding over there actually
look I I've by happy thanks to everybody
thanks for joining us today you know
what I've been using you already gave me
that I've been using a little term
privately and I'm going to start using
this more publicly and I call it I call
it the uninformed narrative puppets
unp's and I hope it catches on because
that reporter is an uninformed narrative
puppet an uninformed puppet trying to go
with the narrative oh it's so hateful oh
it's so hateful but they're not ready to
put anything out there and remember the
headlines and things they put out there
they're uninformed narrative
puppets ter Media Matters and I love how
he called out Media Matters for being
like P
evil so let's uh I agree let's continue
real quick I want to spend two minutes
on this story not a long time bance CEO
oh man CZ to plead guilty to federal
charges steps down um where's he at here
we go binance CE um has pleaded guilty
to Federal charge and steep down as a
part of a $4.3 billion do settlement
with the Department of Justice resolving
in a multi-year investigation to the
world's largest cryptocurrency exchange
Z Express responsibility what happened
no no responsibility I have made
mistakes the joint effort by the
Department of Justice and commodity
Futures Trade Commission and the
treasury Department found that binance
allowed illicit transactions including
those supporting tarff terrorism and
illegal narcotics and failed to
implement anti-money laundering controls
that that right there that right there
you know what that means that sentence
let me read that sentence to you one
more time folks listen the joint effort
Department of Justice
doj the commodity Futures Trading
commission and the treasury Department
they are ecstatic here found that
binance allowed illicit transactions
including those supporting terrorism and
illegal narcotics and Fa to implement
anti money laundering controls you know
what that means crypto is about to be
regulated us attorney general mer
Garland emphasized that binance
prioritized as profits over the safety
of American people as part of the
settlement binance will continue to
operate with new compliance rules and an
independent monitor they do not like
things to be decentralized and
unfortunately the last guy they had to
take out to give the entire crypto
Community Pro libertarian pro-
independent Pro leave it to to me Pro
decentralized all of that they gave them
a black eye and now they don't have
anybody else to go to after this story
go ahead out yeah correct black eye you
hit the nail on the head Pat um this is
just this is just another black guy for
the crypto industry and if you've been
paying I know we have a sort of a bigger
libertarian crypto audience we I have
some Bitcoin ethereum it's something
I've been investing in for for years you
know percentage of my asset allocation
by portfolio but bitcoin's been
what they're up
36,000 they're they're up big in the
last two months big time and it's just
kind of like they can't get out of their
own way first it was Sam bankman freed
now it's binance CZ by the way binance
CZ way bigger than FTX way bigger than
coinbase massive I think they're the
number one crypto platform in the world
by far well the way it was exploding in
the numbers they were using yes um the
the white hat in all this was a guy
named Brian Armstrong who's CEO coinbase
and CZ actually called him when he knew
his ass was in trouble he knew it and
Brian Armstrong came out was like Hey I
told you so there are people that are
trying to push the the good side of
crypto you know personal security
personal you know you an alternative to
C to fiat currency all all these things
on the good ways and then these these
idiots combination of um SPF and CZ have
given the government what they want the
government wants to control everything
and they have played into it and Brian
Armstrong was very very adamant about
this and I'll be adamant about this
something that was good that could
coinist with fiat currency and other
things around the world gets effed up by
Bad actors and here comes the government
hey wait I need to I'll fix that listen
to the three agencies Departments of
governments that Pat just said we've got
law enforcement then we've got you know
C you know Financial regulation we got
everybody that says okay don't mess with
my Fiat there'll be one Central Bank and
it'll be me don't need you guys running
around like this and they're going to
put under control and look I I live in
Miami we all know that Miami sort of
become the crypto Hub of the United
States if not the world and I have
friends in the industry and I've seen
what's going on there and I've
interviewed a lot of people especially
man on the street style in um at the
Bitcoin conference which has been going
on in Miami for the last handful of
years all the events that's going on and
I asked these guys who are huge huge
Believers in Bitcoin and crypto I said
what's your asset allocation strategy
meaning how much do you have in cash how
much do you have in stocks how much do
you have in bonds how much you have in
crypto just kind of like diversification
don't put all your eggs in one basket as
they say you have no idea how many
people are like dude I'm I'm all in I'm
all in on crypto man 100% like how do
you pay rent they're like yeah I keep a
couple bucks just to pay rent whatever
but I'm 100% all in that is a very very
scary situation right because I'm a big
you know keep up percentage in C cash
keep a percentage and majority of my
money is in index funds or mutual funds
or stock market obviously Pat you've
you've got you know 150 million ain't
what it used to be but I know you're big
into the cards and everything and
commodities and gold for that matter I
know you have a little percentage
whether it's 2% or 5% in the crypto
space I've done the exact same thing but
these guys out there that are putting 90
100% of their portfolio in crypto it's
do they know something basic gambling
yeah they they know how to lose money oh
that's what it is well there's a lot
going on and you got the mayor of Miami
Francis Suarez Happy Thanksgiving
Francis um you know paid in crypto he's
I think he's the only us mayor that's
paid in the alternative alternative U
you know currency that's something to
keep an eye on maybe we get a bunch
maybe we get Suarez and a bunch of
people here for podcast future by the
way his mayor swears the stud love that
guy but he gets his mayoral salary in
crypto which is like less than 50 Grand
I would assume he ain't taking his real
money from his legal firm treasury
secretary Janet Yellen said in a release
Tuesday that the exchange allowed
illicit actors to make more than 100,000
transactions that supported activities
such as terrorism and illegal narcotics
that it allowed more than 1 and a half
million virtual
currency traits that violated us
sanctions so it allowed transactions
associated with terrorist groups such as
Hamas alasan brigades Palestinian
Islamic Jihad Al-Qaeda and Isis Yellen
said in the release noting binance never
filed a single suspicious the like what
what the [__] are you thinking you do
dude us right if I'm in that space I'm
so us attorney general mer Garland said
in a press conference Tuesday that the
fine is on the largest uh penalties
we've ever obtained using new technology
to break the law does not make you a
disruptor it makes you a criminal
binance prioritizes profits over safety
American people okay so let me let me
give you what I think back up let me
give you what I think about this year so
for example um only fans all right only
fans you know what the market value of
only fans is what's the number we looked
at the it was a weird number uh uh only
fans market cap yeah you're talking
about 18 billion or 28 billion there's a
only fans market cap 32 billion that's a
big number whatever their market cap is
um uh can you look it up if it's uh
anyway it's a it's it's a big number
it's not a small number what uh only
fans market cap is um so imagine one day
you build this business for fans to find
others and then all of a sudden you're
seeing what it's turning into and you're
like hey man we're kind of get on like
you know money why Pat what's what's
going on on only fans this it's that not
just wholesome family fun guess what you
make a decision it runs off now it's
worth $30 billion okay is it illegal no
but when you think about if if Tom if
you ever went to a uh um business
networking event and a guy asked your
question hey Tom can I get 60 minutes
with you and he said yeah you can find
me on only fans do you know what if you
told me something like that I like a
business networking event I would say
this guy you sell pictures of your toes
you sell pictures like what do you do
what are you sell me it's kind of weird
now by the way here's the thing if you
do want to ask Tom any question and have
a 60-minute call with Tom Vinnie Adam
myself even rob you can find it on man m
i n NE C Rob if you want to put man up
there so people can see it I don't know
you've had 500 plus people ask you
questions on man Tom you're up there God
knows how many different Go download the
app man and connect with anybody you
want and ask them questions there's a
bunch of people you can ask questions on
uh man and they get back to you matter
of fact there was a guy the other day
asked 10 questions of 10 different
realtors who are professional realtor
winners and he he got 10 different
answers on how to win in today's economy
as a realtor so you'll find a bunch of
different people here they can ask
questions on my next but here's the
point uh the the point is with binance
when you see all of a sudden money is
coming in from Al-Qaeda from Hamas for
your CFO comes in and says hey boss
what's that we just saw $5.2 million
from Palestinian Islamic Jihad what do
we do well why don't you just categorize
it
P yeah but it's it's the Jihad yeah how
much money was it this much okay what's
the big deal hey we just got some money
that came in from Al-Qaeda how much was
it 2.2 million hey we just got some I
mean you have to know these are these
are things that you have to pay in a
financial industry we would get some
weird things that would come up very
weird things that would come up that we
have to take a look at it go ahead Tom
you you I feel like you want to say
something no no I'm I'm agreeing with
you uh the suspicious activity report
runs from nuisance all the way to
protection nuisance you sold your car
for $15,000
you go to put money in the bank and
you'll notice if you bring cash to the
window there's you have to initial that
form and say where did this come from
because it's more than $110,000 if you
do that I did this recently and guy had
a cashier check we went to the window
and the lady at Chase says well you you
need to do this what's this for what's
it for well I sold the car who's the
buyer blah blah blah that is a form of a
suspicious activity report one level I
found that kind of intrusive gosh all
they did was sell a car as 15 grand not
150 Grand it's and on the other side
they're trying to protect people and and
here you got binance out there
facilitating transactions with a you
know hi listen I uh I sent $4.5 million
of turkey I didn't get my Stinger
missiles um no no you need to call FedEx
they're the ones delivering those you
know it's binance didn't do what it's
supposed to because we as Americans can
see it and sometimes it's you know
Annoying the example I just gave selling
a car but at the other end of it this is
supposed to protect us when it's like
where's this money coming from
what was bought with this what's going
on giant
transactions for artwork and other
things and jewelry are quickly
explainable big giant chunks of money
for other things like for you know
buying a property are quickly
explainable when you have millions of
dollars going from kahena to Mexico City
and bouncing through um a Bahamian Bank
yeah maybe maybe we should look into
that that's probably a couple tons of
powdered sugar that's moving around and
binance was supposed to be there these
are suspicious activities that the
reporting and the investigation of them
is supposed to give leads to the DEA and
to defenses around the world to protect
citizens and one more thing you know
what Vinnie and I always joke when they
say like nothing to see here nothing
there's always something to see there
and essentially what the this this comes
down to two things fraud and crime and
his basically his inability to even look
the other way when you're talking about
moneya laundering and failing to prevent
moneya laundering I love the example
that Pat gave about only fans yeah it's
like all right nothing to see here it's
all good but there's a big difference
between seeing some titties and seeing
some terrorists and terrorist activities
big difference so at what point when
you're dealing with one the most
powerful quotes you ever given tit is a
terrorist tit is a terrorist place to go
there's a differen is when you're
talking about Islamic Jihad and al-
Qaeda and Isis and Hamas they are in
that category ladies and gentlemen
and just turning a blind eye to this at
what point do your morals become more
important than money and clearly he
didn't give a [__] nope a lot of them
don't all right next Israel and Hamas
reach hostage release deal in exchange
for 4day pause in fighting uh Israel and
Hamas have reached a deal in which
around 50 hostages being held by Hamas
will be released to Israel according to
multiple reports while fighting will
pass for 4 days making a first major
agreement between the two sides since
Hamas October 7th attack the 4-day pause
and fighting will be the first pause
longer than 4 hours that Israel has
agreed to since the fighting escalated
in early October Israel will let 38
trucks in a day cross from Egypt into
Gaza as part of the deal according to
AAS uh according to qari officials
Israel has also agreed to release some
150 jailed Palestinians all women and
children Adam yeah well you know the
famous phrase we do not negotiate with
terrorists well that is exactly what
Israel is forced to do at this point
where they're negotiating with
terrorists and today Thanksgiving we're
all sitting here enjoying life and the
amazingness that is America uh on the
other side of the world they are
basically trying to get their hostages
back um and that's essentially been the
main reason why they have not been um
even willing to have a ceasefire but
it's good to see for Humanity's sake and
for innocent civilians sake that a
ceasefire is pending and today is
supposed to be the day but now they're
essentially supposed to be pushing it
back to Friday and what's holding up the
deal well Hamas has not lived up to
their end of the bargain by providing
any of the details that's supposed to
come with these list of H hostages I.E
names genders details Logistics nothing
and you know luckily the United States
and Israel alongside with Egypt and
Qatar because Qatar is very much
involved in this a lot of hamas's
leadership is based out of qar so there
everyone stepping up and basically
saying listen let's get to the ceasefire
at some point and you know if someone I
I try to equate this into just like
humanistic terms if someone held your
kids hostage and they're like hey just
chill out man like just have a little
ceasefire you're like yeah I'm I want my
kids back I want my children back here
and you're telling me to have a
ceasefire give me my children back and
you know these are the children of
Israel this is the family of Israel and
it's great to see much like in any time
there's a situation that there's women
and children and and uh old people are
going to come first and essentially
essentially the the um the details of
the deal is there's going to be 50 of
the over 200 hostages women and children
initially that are going to basically be
exchanged for 150 Palestinian prisoners
that are apparently also women and
children I don't know why what that
those details are kind of weird but yeah
but so there's this exchange it's sort
of a three to1 exchange Israel has been
notorious notorious if you look I mean
rob you can Google this they will
exchange one Israeli citizen for
hundreds if not thousands of terrorists
or people that are put in jail like
that's how much Israel cares about their
citizens they will literally exchange
one citizen for a
thousand terrorists essentially whoever
is in jail so you can look into that but
um ultimately here's what has to happen
cuz hopefully this takes place there's I
would say there's a high likelihood that
this doesn't take place you're
negotiating with terrorists so we'll see
what happens here but uh if there is
some sort some sort of ceasefire and
exchanging
of prisoners and hostages and everything
that's going on there that's great and
then what they what I I think terms of
the deal is that for every day that
there's a ceasefire there were at least
10 more hostages so we would all love to
see a cation in war and activity and
everything that's going on with that in
the meantime Israel has been attacking
the operational headquarters allegedly
that is in this Hospital area they've
been basically going after tunnels
they've been going after weapons
manufacturing sites and I think it's
come to the world's attention that Hamas
has got to go what needs to happen is
that the UN needs to step up the Red
Cross has already stepped up they're
going to need to basically have set up
some sort of temporary political
solution a un run government to run Gaza
and we would all love to see the ending
of War and the ending of this um it the
only way you bring a terrorist to the
table is you kind of Go Kaiser so on
them right you're willing to go one step
further than they are oh wow and I've
seen the we've seen the videos and one
of the videos most striking to me was
seeing how the Israelis planted you know
a a high-intensity explosive charge from
one end of a tunnel and they set it off
and you saw a back blast but then in the
distance on a like a straight line then
off to the left you saw the blast
effectively coming through like manhole
covers that was air vents and so you're
saying to I'm saying to myself man I
sure hope Israel knew where that tunnel
went and was sure that there were no
hostages and little rooms or caves down
under there because the concussive force
there basically it it it kills people
rather quickly right the concussive
force of an explosion in a contained
area breaks your eard drums creates
inter cranial bleeding and you're dead
and so I just sure hope that Israel knew
that there were no hostages along that
line and where that tunnel was going
number one but number two you look at
that immediately took out any living
thing that was on down that half mile
tunnel and you say to yourself okay guys
if you're hiding in that tunnel you're
no longer hiding there cuz there's there
you guys are all dead and it appears
that Israel had some despite the bad
View and I I hate what I'm seeing here
because I believe in the notion that
when you kill a man with a child and you
leave the child the child and his three
friends are are when they turn 18 16
they're becoming bad guys you're making
bad guys out of these children have lost
their their parents yeah but I believe
Israel's had some Effectiveness with
what they're doing and that's brought
Hamas to the table to negotiate this
well well again America doesn't uh
negotiate with with terrorists I don't I
don't know how Israel or anybody else
does but at what let's say we get they
get all the all these uh hostages back
then then what is that is that endgame
then what it's CU I mean Hamas is still
I apparently out of the what 11,000 that
have been killed the majority are women
and children you guys know how many
Hamas terrorists have been killed in
this in this they have not had concrete
numbers because it's hard to do that
because runs it I don't know I'm not
going to guess I'm not going to guess
but people have guess and it's but 100
or 200 and I'm being give me your source
for that I've heard that not a lot well
it's it's not a lot on can you tell me
how many I don't know that's why I'm not
guessing hold on give me a guess can you
guess I'm not going to guess well I I
from what I've heard give me your best
guess I would say it's under 500 say
it's under 500 out of 10,000 let's just
say my point is at what point is it
going to be like okay so let's say they
do this a four- day ceasefire and then
and they go right back to it what's the
the endgame is is getting all the
hostages back right I mean that's what
that's what you want is to get all the
hostages back but like Tom just said you
killed these innocent people that are
dying you're creating people that are
really really going to hate Israel and
they're really really really going to
hate us and and then here's the point
here's the point that I'm going to did
you guys saw that internal memo that was
released that Israel said Hey listen we
didn't want it to come out with the
media and everybody got it robbed did
you see about this and it was their plan
value tment Conor Walcott reported on it
it was an internal memo saying that all
uh the west and everybody is going to
have to take all these uh refugees
because Israel doesn't want to take them
they they're cuz mind you all these
people are going where right now where
where are all going to refugee camps
okay where on Israel's not the the
Egyptian border is not open the RAF for
crossing that's where they but ask
yourself why won't Egypt take these
people why won't Jordan take these
people in why won't the rest of the Arab
world take these people in ask asking
you because nobody wants people that are
pissed off because they're getting
bombed at them would you want to take
anybody that's a big why didn't they
take them in prior to this what what I'm
saying is though the attitude of well we
told everybody to leave where are they
going they're just going in a camp and
sitting around where are they going to
go curious this sort of highlights the
bigger problem that's going on here and
I equated it to I'm going to make a sort
of a weird analogy what's goes on in
America when um black-on-black crime
like nobody talks about black onblack
crime nobody talks about what's going on
in Chicago nobody talks about what's
going on in DC where are the riots for
that where is the BLM movement when
black people get killed by other black
people but when one cop randomly kills a
black person which is very very seldom
all of a sudden there's riots and
there's protests what's the analogy
we're not talking about what the Arabs
that are killing other Arabs in every
other part of the world in Syria in
Lebanon in North Africa certainly what's
going on in Iran is a [__] [__]
travesty but all of a sudden when Israel
tries to defend themselves and their
right to a sovereign peaceful Nation
they're the bad guys go ahead and March
when uh uh Al Qaeda in North Africa
starts terrorizing other North Africans
and they start killing other Muslims and
Arabs where are the Marchers for that
where are the Marchers you only care
about when the Jews do it's essentially
the same thing that goes on here in
America you don't no BLM isn't marching
when hundreds if not thousands of black
people are killed by fellow black people
where the Marchers say nothing but let
One Cop do something ridiculous the
Marchers and Su it's exactly what's
going on here and if you want to talk
about stats did you see this USA Today
article I'll read it to you because they
actually surveyed the people of Gaza
okay what Tom what are you saying no I'm
saying yes yes yes read that thanks Tom
I don't need your encouragement um so
they basically said it's called support
dude thanks brother go go ahead Adam um
basically they're saying that Hamas has
basically it's it's basically a mini
Iran and you're familiar with Iran of
okay how do you think the people of Iran
feel about their government well some of
them love it not no the majority of
people do not love their government in
Iran well you said some some people do
the majority of people what I don't know
what do STS have have you I'm just your
opinion like where's the stats where's
your poll to give it I don't know gu
some people love their [__] country
ad what would you say do you would you
say the people of Iran love their
government Pat Uh government no they do
not yeah do you need a stat to know that
no we actually gave a report the other
day in the way it opened up according to
a Netherlands uh study that was done 68%
of Iranians in Iran want the government
to be changed of course all right well
it turns out it's exact same thing
that's going on in Gaza okay so if you
look into this thing that says Hamas and
torious for its violent tactics such as
executions and enforced and enforc
disappearances instills a pervasive
atmosphere among who Palestinians in
Gaza this is what happens when a
terrorist organization or a mafia like
organization like the mulas in Iran are
running your government and what happens
is they kill their political Rivals
they're thrown off rooftops they tortur
their own people this is not a democracy
this is a fullon terrorist organization
that is running a country and the people
who suffers the most innocent civilians
in Gaza 50% of which have were born
prior
to Hamas coming into power in 2006
innocent kids innocent victims can't
even go out there and speak so here's
some numbers for you surveys conducted
by the Arab barometer before the October
7th attack provide revealing statistics
68% here are your numbers 68% of gazin
believe they had no safe way to
participate in peaceful protests against
Hamas while 73% favored a peace deal
with Israel this is according to USA
Today these figures underscore the
complex Sentiments of gazen population
where support for Hamas is far from
unanimous so the the the the people that
are suffering the most are the innocent
people of Gaza and the Palestinians
that's the majority of the people that
are there exactly were suffering at the
hands of Hamas so by the way if you look
at Hamas when they were elected in 2006
who was who was running uh basically
Palestine the Palestinians but that it
was mmud abas by the way he's 88 years
old he's he's kept up in the uh West
Bank he has not been to Gaza since 2006
why because they basically had a civil
war and they will freaking kill him
Hamas they're political Rivals okay so
in America here we have you know we'll
lock her up and know you belong in jail
and all that no they'll literally kill
you in Gaza that's what Hamas will do so
it's a sad situation that's going on
there and last point is this they've
actually come out with dozens of reports
they've
interviewed Arab Muslims who live in
Israel and they asked them Point Blank
why don't you leave Israel why do you
stay here they go I I love Israel I have
Economic Security I have Financial
Freedom I'm safe I feel great why don't
you move to Gaza why don't you go to
Lebanon and they're essentially like
hell no I'm good here so all the people
really want in Gaza at the end of the
day at the end of the day what do people
really want Financial Freedom they want
to work they want to earn they want to
be with their family but they're held
hostage by Hamas and Israel lives next
door to a terrorist organization to the
to the west of them is Hamas to the
north of them is Hezbollah to the right
of them is al- Qaeda what the hell are
they supposed to do does anybody want
innocent victims to die hell no but what
are you supposed to do when you have
terror organizations surrounding you
well it's kind of you said the people
what do the people in Gaza want you mean
wanted cuz there is no there it's flat
50% of the people have been
displaced but did Israel want this on
October 6th they had no issues not
saying no issues there was no war and I
want this is a point that I have to make
Pat and we'll move on two things can
exist at the same time What Hamas did I
can everybody can agree horrible
disgusting you can you can understand
and see that but then on the flip side
say like the response is getting a
little bit out of hand you could still
goals can exist you you don't you're not
a Hamas supporter I I want you to play I
want to play this here because uh
again this is this is a conversation
that's been going on for how many how
many weeks now right several weeks and
we've heard all the debates we've heard
all the different debates on what's
going on R can you play the clip on uh
the the the what is it security uh uh uh
Council the National Security Council
advisor to Obama smiles when he's
talking to this man and this video If
you guys saw the face of this man going
around and maybe you didn't watch the
video here's who he was this was the
former National Security Council adviser
his name is Stuart selwitz he was
charged yesterday with a hate crime for
spewing islamophobic rants at a cart
vendor in New York City the the vendor's
name was Muhammad Hussein who's by the
way of Egyptian descent he's American
citizen he was working when Al selwitz
who's Jewish approached him and started
verbally attacking him Muhammad said the
incident was unprovoked and uh he said
that he's going to sue Stewart for hate
speech and harassment and pal I'm I
going to give it away cuz this is 2
minutes long do you want to show the
whole thing or just at the end when he
says and I quote uh if we killed 4,000
Palestinian kids let let let him watch
this play don't play lman will fast it's
going to be yeah okay go ahead to my
friends in Immigration he's calling his
friends in Immigration the Egyptian the
muat wants your picture go yeah look at
that evil face you know the mhat HM the
muhabat
no I don't know you don't know I just
speak English no yeah go out in in Egypt
will get your parents your father like
his fingernails they'll they'll take
them out one by one Jesus
that go go why should I go why should I
go tell me why I should go I'm standing
here I'm an American I have free it's a
free country it's not like Egypt
jeez fast forward halfway go right keep
going a little more right there what who
Muhammad Muhammad your your Prophet you
know who he is my Prophet yeah he was a
rapist he raped Aisha does it say that
in the Hadith or not you know that I
don't speak English what no English you
don't speak English what do you
speak with that face dude what do you
speak you speak Arabic the language of
the
Quran the Holy
Quran that some some people use is a
toilet
jeez what do you think of that people
who use the and here it comes here it
comes does it bother
you watch what he says at the
end does it bother you tell me the truth
I don't speak English you don't speak
English that's too bad that's why you're
selling food in a in a food cart cuz
you're already you're ignorant but you
should learn English it'll help you of
course when they deport you back to
Egypt and theat wants to interview you
for being
a I sent you I sent you one Robin slack
which at the end of it pat the one you
can say what he said okay so I'm I'm
going to say what he says and Rob cuz I
slacked you the one at the end at the at
the one minute uh 40 mark uh he says I
mean you have you have to hear him say
it I sent it this is it right here Pat
i' rather have you guys hear it from him
and this is just pure hate so far so far
there's no crime here so far well what
do you mean well he got arrested for a
hate crime no he get there's no crime
until this happens correct watch that
yeah go to the he's showing by the way
he puts an Israeli flag is this a
different video support go go to a
little bit towards the end Rob it's like
right right towards the end listen go
I'm not terrorism I'm not some go I'm
just children watch watch here we go
you're a terrible person you kill
children not me what go my kids what
about my kids you kill children not me
go I didn't kill children okay see here
you know why if we killed 4,000
Palestinian kids you know what it wasn't
enough look at that it wasn't enough it
wasn't enough that's Obama's National
Security Council adviser so there's dude
that's just evil hatred in your heart
just his face just his Vibe it's like
that's disgusting bro and he got
arrested yesterday I fully agree with
you the guy's a total scumbag and it's
indefensible by by the way Rob can we
play the video of all the Arabs
basically calling for uh the death of
all Jews do you have any of those videos
because there's billions of them here's
the point these anomalies out here just
interviewing one person they're not
representative of an entire Faith or an
entire ideology so is that guy a scumbag
yes but does he represent all Jews or
all Israelis hell no just like Hamas
doesn't represent all Arabs yeah nobody
said that they were the point is this
boy this Obama's boy which is hilarious
dude I don't care if he's Obama's boy
Trump's boy because believe me Trump has
people that are just the story though
that's the story the story is that he
was working in our government in a
trusted position of influence control
and power for a US president and then
he's on the street like this I don't
think anybody was was trying to make a
sweeping generalization about Jewish
people Arabic people this is a guy that
was in our government that's the story
and he's choosing to behave like this
and he knows record and he was in a
Liberal Liberal globalist um regime the
Obama Administration that's the story I
fully agree I don't know who this guy is
I'm not defending him told we just told
you he but the point is what's the point
we're just singling this one guy Adam
it's a story in the news I don't know if
you know this the pbd podcast we do news
this is Barack Obama's National Security
adviser he's in the street in front of a
camera saying we should have killed more
palestin children understand the point
he's making but it's not like we're
singling out one no no the point he's
making is there's extreme people like
this as well on the other side that
doing some ridiculous thing my my
biggest challenge is that this is
increasing the temperature and people
like like him are increasing it even
more by the things that they're saying
being able to control their emotions and
for somebody that lives in America you
have to realize the people that live in
Poland they're number one priority is
what Poland Poland the people live in
Australia their number one priority is
what Australia people who live in US
guess what's their number one priority
should be us if you got a family that
should be your number one priority now
I'm Iranian Syrian and Armenian whenever
something happens over there that that
tugs on my heart and I'm I'm part of it
so I understand as a person that that's
Jewish or somebody that's Palestinian or
somebody that's Muslim or somebody that
whatever may be they're going to have
their emotions being uh uh involved
because it's Heritage it's pride in your
background who you are but at the same
time the the fact that these
temperatures are not decreasing at the
levels that we need concerns me in today
where yesterday a guy driving a Bentley
is flying into a Canadian border blowing
up and CN and fox and everybody says
there was explosive stuff in the vehicle
and yeah is that the one watch this
video with this car just
flying look at the background I think it
was like 110 miles hour back identifying
who OCC of the hell is do any potential
they may have in terms of in groups they
may belong to the audio we're not
listening to what she's got to say just
want to watch what do he doing dude and
by he's going from Canada to here that's
how bad it is in Canada they're driving
110 miles an hour to get the freak out
of there Justin tro that's should be a
video get the hell out of that's the
truest thing you've said all a new
meaning to I don't need any facts for
that yeah we don't need a fact check for
small small unsuccessful division of
Eric canadaa here okay let's go to the
next one let's go to the next story 40%
of Americans are afraid to walk alone at
night most in decades this is a Miami
heral story let's see what this is the
herald so all right so con about certain
crimes in the US are at the highest
levels in decades despite a decrease in
violent crime Nationwide a gallopo found
that 28% Americans worry about being
murdered a near high and 72% worry about
falling victim to identity theft
additionally 50% worry about their cars
being stolen or broken into 37% fear
being mugged and 32% are concerned about
being attacked while driving the
heightened fear has led to a significant
impact on daily life with 40% Americans
being afraid to walk alone at night
within a mile of their home the highest
number in three decades crime concerns
also prevent 34% from driving in certain
areas 28% from attending events and 28%
from speaking to strangers does any of
this apply to you uh are you concerned I
mean p Pat you know me I'm I I love
living in Florida cuz I'm armed all the
time but what what do you expect Pat
when you have not only the open border
uh you can steal up to whatever what
$1,000 and underneath the defund the
police attitude has made cops not give a
[__] cuz they don't want to they why
would you want to help if you were a cop
everybody's watching you everybody's
trying to record you and see if you if
you f up I think I think people should
be concerned and you should be armed and
you should take care of yourself because
at the end of the day P when [__] it's
the fan who's going to help you you're
going to stop and like hold on one
second let me call 911 to a cop that can
give two shits now because the country's
been [__] on them for the past 5
years no it's you have to protect
yourself and I'm I don't I good good
guys be be worried and be scared with an
open border with the sentiment that
we've had towards cops with with uh
States saying you know what steal as
much as you want who get this just long
as it's they're incentivizing people to
stealing [__] yes I I think everybody
should be worried and you should be
armed and you should take care of
yourself because nobody's going to help
you yeah I'm increasingly concerned
about personal security but I don't let
it affect you know that I'm too scared
to go outside or not do things in life
you know I still go to football games I
still go out and shop I still do things
but I'm hyper aware and with a a
daughter who's about to go off to
college in you know 9 months from now
she's going to be going up to college we
talk about uh personal protection we
talk about you know the things you do
when you get out of a car in a parking
lot you know looking around and it's
just there's there's more training and
more awareness and more just being
because if you if you do these things
and I set her up with a license so she
can get pepper spray and all that kind
of stuff if you do all that then you can
live more comfortably and and not just
be scared looking over your shoulder I
would hate to live a life where I was
just scared looking over my shoulder
every day I want to feel perfectly
comfortable and unconcerned going to the
ATM going to the store going to the
beach going to a football game but you
know what you know I've got precautions
I've you know I've you know you can get
a carry permit you can get your children
set up at the right age you know to be
trained in use of pepper spray and
things and so you you have plan B why do
you have a fire extinguisher in a a
kitchen just in case but you don't worry
about every day I hope there's not a
fire I hope there not a fire but you
have what you need when you need it
that's how I want to live life is live
life not you know stupid and unassuming
and walk into something and I should
have been looking around and paying
attention but I want to live life
comfortably with freedom and and have a
a degree of of just piece about myself
when I go out but I will have fire
extinguishers well I'll tell you what
these stats uh they're alarming and
they're just quite frankly sad so the
the 28% of Americans for worried about
being murdered okay 72% fall victim to
Identity that 50% worried about their
cars 37 being mugged 32% being attacked
while driving it's it's absurd so this
just sort of gives Credence to the
American first ideology it's like we're
trying to be a policemen of the world
and in some instances we should because
if if America takes a a step back who
then leads the world China Russia Iran
the axes of evil hell no but at the same
time we do need to take care of America
we see these open border policy
basically ruining America something that
wasn't an issue until Trump made an
issue but it was obviously the news
perpetuated the racist wall and all that
now we're looking back at it and Biden's
like you know what may we Build That
Wall buddy you know so we see what's
going on here so um the the the rot
within America and American society to
decline American values is real It's
just sad to see and guess what gun
that's because of these stats that's why
gun sales are at an alltime High people
aren't being by the way they're every
year they're get higher higher and and
can I be dead serious with you when you
are armed Pat legally armed and
protected I don't feel as scared because
I know that I'm going to take care of
myself if [__] does hit the fan that's
why I roll with Vinnie as my body do you
know do you know what percentage of
Iranians own a gun in Iran in Iran
7.3% how they get you know what
percentage of Americans own a gun 120%
let's go baby did you notice that or no
hold up what percentage of a a gun
ownership worldwide legal
legal some people have is this guns
divided by population yeah it's
percentage of do they have it um broken
down by how many people actually own a
gun like I think it's like probably 25%
of Americans I don't know what what I'm
saying go right there zoom in right
there saying gun ownership us is
120% Serbia's 39 Uruguay's 35 Canada's
35 finland's 32 look at number two yeah
faulin Island so they still don't trust
the British first or last in other words
what this tells me is Rob can you do me
a favor a do you know what the former
National Security
Council you mean the guy at the F cart
oh the guy that said hide your wife hide
your kids your
husb play this clip it's by far the best
one if I just texted it to you uh and
then go to a minute five I mean this
thing was so popular that it became a
rap song you know have you seen a sing
or amazing Antoine datson turns into a
rap song oh yeah could they ring
everybody up in here yeah yeah just go
to minute five there's certain this 10
years ago this was you couldn't escap
ago
the equivalent of the big black guy with
the uh black bar certain hits certain
hits are good to minute five oh and the
picture of the leprechaun yeah right
right was that part of it watch this PR
obviously we have a rapist in Lincoln
Park he's climbing in your windows he's
snatching your people up trying to rape
them so y'all need to hide your kids
hide your wife and hide your husband
because they raping everybody out the
attacker got loose and went out if this
is the by the way is this the hold on
see if there's a picture of the guy was
that part of this by the way keep
pressing play said and your husbands cuz
they're raping
everybody oh God Rob Rob don't turn out
the audio let us listen to he go you I
think they hadir that fingerprints and
all you are so dumb you are really dumb
for real a crime scene investigator
photographed and dusted for prints on
the lid of the garbage can and the
window pain and ledge Dodson says he's
never seen the the per before but sends
this warning to whoever is responsible
you don't have to come and confess that
you did we're looking for you we we
going to find you I'm let you know n so
you can run and tell that home booy
homeboy
yeah Antoine dson for president oh bro
can you imagine he had no idea while he
was doing that he was going to go viral
we raping everybody up by the way that
was over 10 years ago I want to say that
was under the Obama 10 years ago years
is he doing speeches now
interet we went from gun ownership to
this let's go to the next one Rob can
you pull up what Morning Joe said which
is just tells you how much uh where
we're going to next year the amount of
the amount of fear they want to put into
the American voter is just out of
control do you know which clip I'm
talking about uh yeah morning Joel right
there that one right there watch this
play this clip I hate these I hate these
two look at this you're got to look like
idiots uh because he will do he will get
away with he will imprison he will
execute whoever he's allowed to imprison
execute uh uh uh uh drive from the
country ju just look at his past execute
you should be held accountable for using
words like that never what do you mean
they're Le let's flip it around let's
flip it around that is Brett Bayer goes
on a rant and says Obama he will do he
will imprison he will retaliate Obama
will execute anyone what happens to
Brett Byer does fire next day exactly
beay not Byer sorry whatever the hell
his name is it's just unbel no my point
is you know I Brett represents a
position very clearly so do he's a Beed
man he's a be
man man he's a be bu every a bad B when
the bow breaks the crater will fall and
it has fallen here but not my C
but not my boy he didn't saell you up
the river you have to think about it
though Pat like I I hope every Daddy's
pocket I hope everybody's paying
attention cuz this is the the the bigger
picture cuz history is starting to
repeat itself mainstream media is
already starting with this [__] uh
Hitler's coming back and orange man
mainstream media this is the sad part
because I know these guys are panicking
mainstream media is reporting already
CNN everybody Trump is beating Biden in
the polls right Pat let's pay attention
pay attention to what's happening
however mle the argentinia Trump just
became president right mle yesterday the
Dutch Donald Trump geared wilderson one
of the Netherlands celebrities who
suffer from trun derangement syndrome
are now turning and they're bashing
Biden uh openly okay and then one week
at mind you history time is coming full
circle the dictator xingping visits
America and now all of a sudden there's
a a covid like flu that's tearing
through China okay notice how it's all
starting to come around it's election
year Trump is number one the left the
left is turning on him the the poll
numbers they're reporting celebrities
now no look that China for more there's
a rise of illness and pneumonia clusters
I saw I sent rob a video Rob I sent you
a video it looks exactly like when they
were trying to start telling us Pat
about covid and they had those videos at
those propaganda videos where uh Chinese
people with masks were dying in the
street but they were catching themselves
when they fell down do you have that
video that I sent you up yeah this is
this is what's happening in China right
now and it's it's in Chinese so maybe
Aaron could come in here and translate
but look at the Overflow of this
everybody's all these people are like
it's starting again and by the way I
wouldn't be surprised she comes to visit
he might have brought this here with us
and and given it to Biden he's like Hey
listen you take this and if you know you
want to win the election you want to
stay in the basement release this 20
this is ridiculous Pat like people don't
see it you don't see what's happening
you think that's you're going to the
point where you think that's what's
taking place I'm I'm going to well you
think they're going to be able to get
away with the Playbook they use in 2020
with Americans are Pat the average
American you mean those idiots that are
lining up let me ask you a question so
how did how did Mele win in Argentina
how did gear Wilder win how did these
guys win I mean go go to gear Wilder who
just won and everybody says the
anti-islam anti-eu populist who could be
the next Dutch pm and they're calling
him the next Trump so anybody that is a
conservative is a far right 100%
candidate is who they are melee is a
Libertarian and this guy is also going
around doing what he's doing and you
know in football and in
basketball um you you put a play very
rarely will a team do the same play back
to back because the defense is now able
to read the play that you're going to do
very rarely you're going to do that yeah
if they try to do the same play as they
did in 2020 which that was very
effective you have to come up with a
more more creative play than that and
you you don't you you don't have someone
to hate today they're trying to get the
world to hate Trump because that was the
playbook for 2020 they're having a hard
time doing that because they're saying
well listen man as much as we you we
want to hate Trump even what's the actor
that the other day said I can't believe
I'm they want to hate him so bad they
want to hate him so bad but they still
got to vote for the guy yeah okay they
want to hate him so bad but they're
looking at the conditions they're
looking at Israel they're looking at
Palestine they're looking at you know
the way we left Afghanistan they're
looking at Ukraine they're looking at
Russia they're looking at what's going
on here and they're saying you know what
if I have to choose between Biden and
him so they don't have a same argument
to put that kind of a fear into them
they just don't have that and I think
that's going to be problematic for them
so so and the fear that is in them is
reality reality is landed on them like a
ton of bricks with fear causing them to
make logical decisions out of that fear
and that is exactly we we showed the
clip on the podcast uh three home teams
ago where chamoth came out and did an
analysis of his own thinking and now how
his and I won't say fears but his
apprehensions and observations of what
was really happening in the world
through the lens of history as time pass
led him to go back and say not that I
was wrong but my views have changed and
this is what I'm worried about today
this I'm concerned about my today and
this is how this is how I vote today but
Vinnie I know what saying I understand
you're saying here they go again here
they go again but Americans you play the
here I go again on Americans they are
not closing schools here not closing
restaurants you guys are G you guys are
giving the average by the way Biden and
Trump it's 48 49% that 48% that still
loves Biden those are the people lining
up to get their fifth booster they're
driving in their cars with their mask
you guys are giving the average American
P I think way too much credit obviously
it's not our viewers cuz they're all
smart we the average American doesn't
run it though the average American
doesn't run the election so so you mean
okay so Pat ready for this the left
there can't be stupid the Trump
indictment [__] is backfiring 100% okay
they're losing control they're seeing
what's happening in the world if you had
to guess Pat what trick do they have up
their sleep they have to be doing
something there's no way they're going
to be this calm and they dude for Chi
Jing ping there only one trick left with
a with with it's it's getting rid of him
right that's the only one that's left
well that's the only one that's left
because since 2015 till now in eight
years you know you know when you got a
how many trickery plays does a coach
have how many three or four really good
one okay well let's just say very very
good one has how many say 20 yeah a team
the other day tried the trickery play
that they did in college and they tried
to do it in the NFL at backfired on them
was a late delayed uh what do you call
it lateral pass uh no no there's a
there's a word for it the fusi no anyway
so the point is they've played every
single trick in the book the last eight
years on him and they're done they have
nothing else left but to get one person
that's crazy enough to go to the golf
course or to do something like that that
is the only thing that's left right now
they're sitting there you know what
they're all thinking to themselves
they're all sitting there saying holy
[__] this guy's about to be the
president there's an article that came
out the other other day that
said um the the Playbook of Democrats
not mentioning is name is gone out the
window did you see this one where uh uh
uh the Democrat media is now where was
that article time I read that on Drudge
Report or something I don't know I know
what you're talking about it was Biden's
First full year after inaugurating we're
not even going to mention him anymore
yeah the Playbook of using Trump's name
anymore is out the window Democrats not
using Trump out the window some title
like that Rob if you can find it what's
the point oh here you go two days ago
New York Times title is ignore Trump
Democrats now want him plastered all
over the place guess what they are so
obsessed about this guy they are so de
ignore Trump Democrats now want and
plastered all over the news the former
president has been relatively quiet out
of headlines and off mainstream social
media Democrats are hoping that more
attention on him help turn around
President Biden's fortunes they don't
understand for for the longest time
they're said we're just not going to
talk about it we're just not going to do
Clips we're just not now they're like oh
[__] he's going to win we got a freaking
light that's what they did last time and
they empowered him people like this
Vinny when you go through a breakup and
something happens like or or there's a
falling out somebody leaves and like
when I left um the former company never
once Tom will tell you this the
trainings were all about how bad I was
from them and people would send me
videos of what the CEO of that company
is saying about me in a meeting oh wow
to another carrier that's a massive
insurance company saying you can do
business with any company but one okay
and that's you know with me you can go
anywhere but one you can go to any
company we will not Sue you but you go
to path we'll sue you wow it was
anywhere but us guess how many times in
training we mentioned their names we
never talked about them because we're
we've moved on and guess what they kept
doing they use names one guy that's a
big guy motivational platform all this
stuff names rumors constantly over and
over and over and over again you know
what he kept doing one day we're at Las
Vegas I have a convention going on Las
Vegas I'm across the street from them in
their meeting all they kept saying is US
bashing over and over and over and over
and over again guess what my Instagram
is doing all of a sudden I'm getting
bombarded with Instagram videos with the
speeches their own people are sending me
speeches and then one guy comes over to
us and says hey I have to know who you
are man because this entire convention
was about you wow in front of their 12
13,000 people they have all they want to
talk about is what's going on with us
you know what happened they came over of
course thank you for the they came
overom so the point is they don't
realize you think this is working it's
not working people are over you bitching
and whining and complaining why you
don't have an argument the way you win
and by the way this was a mistake of
trump as well Trump's mistake was right
after he's like well it's not fair it's
not fair it's not fair it's not fair
it's not fair constantly and I called it
on myself when we were on the like
listen you seem grumpy you've you're
allowing them to make you be grumpy go
back to policies go back to results go
back to what worked go back to your
strategy go back to what you did to
America go back to what happened to the
first three years of US economy if you
do that people are like oh he's right oh
he's right oh he's right oh he's instead
of you you know I just don't get any
credit I just don't this no just go back
and give the argument what you did so
now Trump has to stick to that Playbook
and do what he does these guys behind
closed doors are losing their minds
because you know what they're thinking
to themselves here's what they're
thinking to themselves they didn't have
to do this if Trump was the president
their time was coming up he was about to
be done in a year I exactly great point
would been you guys would have been done
with Trum guess what they intent they
accidentally accidentally forced it upon
themselves to have to talk about Trump
for four more years and not only that
you know what these four years did you
know these three years four years that
Trump wasn't presidented it validated
that all his policies many of them were
great policies exactly that was the best
part about the break of him only being a
one- term break second term this could
end up being a story to say the fact
that he wasn't a back-to-back president
validated that his policies were good
because if he was backto back then they
can spin it and say well it was terrible
policies as embarrassing as it was for
him to be a one- term if he wins the
break could historically be end up
turning into the best break that
validated all of Trump's policies were
great wow Rob can you put the New York
Times that's crazy P for reason at the
the headline thing the head just a
little subhead right there so Democrats
are hoping more attention on him Trump
can turn around Biden's fortunes you
know why they say it this way you know
why the New York Times write it that way
cuz President Biden doesn't have
anything to sell that people are buying
and they're hoping that the attention on
Trump causes Biden's polls to go up no
you've got nothing to sell when you sell
Vision when you sell Freedom when you
sell safety when you sell education when
you sell something and you sell border
and you sell build it in American and
American jobs people are buying there is
nothing that Biden is selling that
people are buying I I just I will tell
you what what what he's got to use if
I'm Biden's uh campaign manager I have
to show gas prices are lower this year
so he has to show that he has to show
and find a way to take credit for the
ceasefire you have to do that then they
he has to find a way to show that
Thanksgiving food prices are less this
year than they were last year he has to
do that they have to use those things
they have to use it you know but but
this strategy of Democrats are hoping
that more attention on him can help turn
president do you know who's this B by
the way if you if I wouldn't have shown
you who this article was from you would
have said this is Fox Business or Fox
News re read the whole thing New York
ignore Trump Democrats now want him
plered all over the news the former
president has been relatively quiet out
of the
headlines and and by the way typically
they don't even say former president
they'll say Mr Trump headline because
they hate calling him former president
of course and off mainstream media
Democrats are hoping that go up Rob to
show what website this is this is New
York Times oh wow yeah when New York
Times is writing articles like this
you're in trouble Big Time totally so I
think you both guys really good points
one one is a policy thing Tom and one is
a personality thing uh
pbd uh policy-wise what percentage of
Americans vote via policy probably 20%
most people vote on personality well
they don't call it that they think about
their wallet or their job right um but
he Biden actually does have some W's
that he can put up out there whether
it's the inflation reduction act or
whether it's the infrastructure whether
the ceasefire happens there are some
policy wins that he can highlight but
most people don't vote via um policy
they look at the personality and Tom
you're absolutely right on this if
you're just going to try to highlight
Biden's personality the old sort of
aloof dementia esque type person it's
not a winning strategy so their strategy
is like all right well we can't
highlight Biden we're going to have to
highlight Trump and they're going to
paint him in a negative light obviously
so that's sort of their focus we're
going to see if that works this time but
I think we're in a collision course for
uh Trump versus the media part three
yeah Trump won number one the media won
number two and we're about to see what
happens in 2024 when the media tries to
take on Trump for the third time at the
very least the media should understand
this uh when Trump's in office your
ratings go way up so if you're looking
at just money and not ideology just go
ahead and vote CNN has Brian stelter's
back talking on CN back on CNN I saw him
talk yeah I don't know if he still look
like a thumb he's still disgusting I
just hate looking at his freaking ugly
ass face Vinnie Vinnie don't be so
personal that's no the problem I think
is People Like Us need to start saying
to hell with the bro how long we going
to let them walk over us because here's
by the way that smile really pisses me
off it's just I want people to realize
like okay obviously Joe Biden's not
going to run let's let's not be stupid
they he would be good on unusual
suspects who Brian stelter yeah oh he's
very unusual but Pat my my thing is this
he's like a less good-look non-bearded
Rob gar julo no Rob is way better
looking as I said not as good looking
I'm just saying here here's my point not
as funny and talented is we if I had to
bet my money and I'd bet a lot of it
Biden's not going to run I it's going to
be Nome I wouldn't put it past Michelle
not wanting to do it them saying listen
you're going to do it cuz you have to do
it my point is this what is going cuz
Pat okay let's say it's not you know it
might be terrorist thing it might be a a
a new pandemic number two do not sleep
on the Democrats for coming up with
something to not let us vote and you
have to vote from home that that's my
one point and I'm saying it right now so
when it does happen I want to tell
everybody I told you guys so that it was
going to happen it's going to happen Pat
there's no way they're going to just go
okay everybody go vote go vote for Nome
I don't put it past them I'm just saying
cannot use the same Playbook it's going
to have to be a new playbook they have
to use not the co play so you don't
think people so so you guys don't think
a if they said right now late breaking
news this covid-19 or whatever it's
coming from try to happen again
Americans wouldn't lock the [__] down
and the CDC and the who would freaking
way you you I you you give us too much
credit As Americans I tell you that part
will be no you really think I say that
part will be no you think they already
set everything up but but I'm telling
you they have to come up with another
creative strategy I have a question
for ask b a question this this I could
ask you off camera but I think it's a
better for camera so um you came from La
yeah via New York you were in the
Hollywood scene the comedy scene you
were amongst them the Liberals okay um
as for you as no not really I'm from
Florida bro this is very purp oh you
weren't you weren't on a certain show I
forgot let me drink this really quick
Adam ask question here's my question Tom
does great at interrupting but um since
you've obviously been here and been more
exposed to this you've sprinted right
clearly I want to know your relationship
with all your friends back home did they
see what you're doing now and they're
like Vinnie I'm disussed with you
they're like kind of have a point like
where you at with everyone that you've
been associated with for the last decade
that's a freaking that's a great
question cuz one of these just happened
yesterday I'm getting a lot of the
people that were technically hiding and
kind of in the closet with the Trump not
Trump lovers I I hate to say like that
just what he was basically standing for
is is F the F the system the majority of
them now are like Vinnie I love I see
what you're doing good for it but then
the the the hardcore Trump World War III
Russian agent blah blah those are some
silent ass people right now but Adam I
message them once in a while and I go so
how's it going how's your how's your
how's your money doing how's the border
now they're worried about ter
antagonizing oh not antagonizing them
Adam because I think we have to come to
a point where we go like this now we
told you so I [__] told these people
you're being duped you're being how how
many times and I hate to be this guy but
I kind of don't how many times do I have
to be right how many times do I have to
say the Russian collusion thing was fake
how many times we have to say all that
Hillary was in charge of it Hillary
cheated uh and the DNC China Bernie how
many more coincidences have to happen
where people wake up I don't give a [__]
what side are you on when it's wrong
it's wrong so I didn't lose any friends
from the right uh the ones that were
kind of right but the the ones on the
left at them they're just silent and
they're just swallowing it right now a
lot of them are Mo by the way a lot of
them that were hardcore leftists moved
out they they're back home I go why why'
you move why' you leave Los Angeles well
[__] crime and and the taxes and I go
oh but it was cool on the Trump you were
there chilling and talking [__] but you
were safe and you were [__] making
money I go now all of a sudden you have
to leave so I was right so I think Co
just exacerbated the all the is no they
were still there no they were they were
they were still there but then and then
again you have to ask yourself the
question how coincidence that during
election year this thing comes out of
[__] China where Trump was talking [__]
about and they're still not accountable
still no accountability every week is
another FBI story where they're like
well it could be a lab leak when are we
going to stop playing this lab we still
don't know all these years later we
can't admit that it came from there Pat
what when is the game going to stop
guess what that's why there's elections
M and that's why the people who don't
want to see that happen in
2024 who are sick of it have to be vocal
have to be more involved have to have
better arguments have to be better at
selling have to be better at convincing
have to get their peers involved have to
have better rebuttal have to do better
research have to have answers based on
facts and stats and data and the better
prepared you are as you're talking to
other people who are giving you whatever
their arguments are and the enough of
the reasonable people and the guys that
sat on the fence or were sitting on the
bench last time saying I don't want to
vote are going to come out and say nah
this is I'm not with this and then 2024
could be a different result but all I'm
saying to you
is don't
underestimate you know the the the last
couple presidential assassinations and
attempts that's happened you know how
many of them have been involved with the
opposition winning you know johnf
Kennedy gets assassinated 4 days later
LBJ is saying let's start a war and you
know weapons the the military industrial
complex people are like yeah Pro LBJ
what a great guy you are making us all
this money so was it LBJ was it who who
was involved in that situation the
people that Tred to kill uh uh you know
Reagan the assassination of Reagan
that's also linked to somebody else so
there's a lot of weird things that could
happen I if there's anything that needs
to be very very important is keeping him
as secure and safe as possible and
taking security to different measures
today you just have to do it today
because um they don't have a lot more
plays out of their playbook does he
still have Secret Service yeahum of
course Trump junor doesn't oh Pat called
the Flea Flicker the Flea Flicker where
they throw it back and you do the hell
Mar that was that was a play that you
were talking about all right so let's go
to the uh let's go to a couple of ones
here and then we'll wrap up um 15% tip
let's talk about this one you most
Americans tip 15% or less okay or less
um all right let me go to this that's a
pretty crazy and some tipping this is a
CNBC story Pew research survey surveys
11,945 Americans found that 18% of
people tip less than 15% for an average
meal at a sitdown restaurant and an
additional tip
2% tip I'm sorry an additional 2% tip
nothing at
all one out of 50 people in America that
go to dinner don't tip anything at all
mean while 37% said 15% is their
standard tip revealing a lack of
consensus on tip and Getti kid despite
the tradition of tipping 15 to 20% for
sitdown restaurant service the survey
found that more than half of people 57%
tip 15% or less this indicates that
tipping Norms vary widely amongst
Americans studies suggest that tip
fatigue has led to declining tip amounts
in recent times with the average
Nationwide tip at full service
restaurants falling to
19.4% in the second quar of 2023 Tom has
a story here Tom I want to go to you
first go for it what happened to you
this last week at this restaurant called
Capitol Grill which I think is out of
bokeh if I'm not mistaken that's that's
correct go for it nothing to do with
Capital Grill Steve that we love in
Crescent in Dallas who crushes it he's
amazing one of the best servers in the
world he's one of the goats go ahead Tom
so first of all the people at a
restaurant are are not robots every
location is different and God bless you
Steve we love you down there at uh if
you go down by the Crescent in Dallas
and you go to Capital Grill and you ask
for Steve you are not going to get bad
service um but unfortunately so Brooker
gets straight A and she's doing really
well I say hey Brooker let's go to
dinner and we sit down and she gets to
Surly Temple and we're going to have
this and we were just freaking ignored
you know the the step one you know the
the the hostess wants to put it at this
table that they had put up for a
Saturday and it's right next to doors
you know what I'm talking about Pat you
have the same reaction I do it's like
come on that table isn't even there
Monday through Friday all respectful am
out sitting there when we sat down they
they come up and they're they're they're
quick when they they didn't come check
on us you know you normally you go to a
good place you order steak and that's
what we had you cut into it once and a
lot of times at Ruth Chris they say will
you please cut into your steak is that
exactly the way you want it you know
what I'm talking about I love that and
they always do that is that exactly the
way you want it thank you so much and
and they check on the spot this they
drop it down and I want to get a refill
for for Brook Shirley Temple and the
lady walks away excuse me excuse me I
feel like I'm hollering at her walking
down the hall and so I got the hostess
who sat the other table and said could
you help me here you know and I said to
her the aliens that have taken our
server can you let them know that Brooke
would like refill surley Temple and she
goes what I and I said can we do this
and just stacked up and I was very
frustrated and disappointed and I'm like
and and and my steak was cooked wrong
and so I I son of a [__] and so I don't
even get I don't even get the
opportunity there and so I finally just
I said to Brooker I said Brooker we're
going to go someplace sells for dessert
and there was just an assortment of
things so you know I flagged the server
down and I said I'd like to pack up to
go please and I handed her handed her my
card and she's like what and I left a
note on there and I said you know what
what you know I put a little note on
there no profanity with a zero tip and
went down the street to a and Lou walked
in said to the hostess do you have a
table for two for dessert and now this
is like 8:30 she said we sure do and I
said we came from another place I did
not tell him it was Capital girl I said
we came from another place and my
daughter got straight A's and I just
want her treated royalt royalty and
dessert was supposed to be part of it
and she said no problem I'm taking you
to Charlie and Charlie treated Brooke
like he was her long lost Uncle she
wanted hot tea he came over and he
opened the box of tea slowly just
demonstrating service and you know what
I did to Charlie I made his freaking
night and I thanked him profusely for
making Brooke feel like a million bucks
which is all I wanted but I'm my normal
tip I'm 20% Baseline and if I get really
good service I'll go 2530 I normally am
there to encourage and appreciate G
you're a good Tipper if time comes
you're going to get a good good tip from
him so so so you ended up tipping him
how much uh I gave I gave Charlie 200
bucks 200 bucks for how much was the
bill 40 bucks for two desserts and then
and teas so he got 400% 500% tip is what
he got that's really what it is if you
think about it okay I what happens with
me I go to Louis boss remember how we
used to go to Louis bossi in in bokeh
all the time oh and they treated us
royally it was freaking awesome I don't
recognize anybody there we went with the
family the other day and I asked to sit
at the corner table the hostess just
turns her back against me doesn't say
anything I'm like oh okay maybe these
guys are crazy busy they were not
finally we come back kid comes Jennifer
comes in with the kids I said we'd like
to get a table in the corner they take
us to the table in the corner waitress
comes and saying is it water for
everybody and uh we said uh yes and I
said is there any way you can lower the
AC uh temperature here it's very very
cold maybe turn it off
nope just with a no I swear to God cuz
that's the word the kids have been
joking around about the entire weekend
ladies in her mid-40s you're talking to
a grown man she says Nope I said I'm
sorry I said Babe let's get out of here
half a second we got up she said no no
no no no I'm sorry I'm I said no ma'am
you're you don't talk to a grown man
like this no I'm so sorry I didn't mean
that I said no you'll never see me here
ever again by the way Tom how many times
have you seen me go to a restaurant I'll
never come back here and never again
you'll never see me there ever again I
can tell you you've personally
experienced this with me with but it's
only a few because you know what you
know what we do we give people what's
called patronage and we keep coming back
for lunch and they always Louis bossi we
used to have all these people the best
it was the best and how many times a
week would we go to Louis bossi honestly
Adam if you were to eight days a week I
mean you ate there all the time you
honestly right now say if you and I for
these seven for the year that we worked
at bokeh how many times did you and I go
to Louis Basi together with people how
many times collectively total in a year
many we probably eat there at least 50
times but that's just with him that
doesn't mean with other people we were
always at you were cheating on me what
you say you so check this out so we get
up and the kids are like okay they've
seen this before so like okay all right
so what we going to next and we start
looking everybody's hungry so we're
driving around we said okay I'm
explaining to the kids says Daddy what
just happened why did that lady say nope
yeah I said okay I said number one um
you you don't talk to customers like
that however when I was younger I was
coming up I wanted very very good
respect and service everywhere I went
but guess what I haven't deserved it who
the hell are you to give you the great
resp respect you going to Chipotle bro
you're spending 10 bucks we're not
giving you great service you're going to
get what you're getting for the money
now restaurants like Chick-fil-A which
and free free food poisoning at Chipotle
the the the data you'll give here in a
minute with Chick-fil-A which is very
important to realize most restaurants go
to any McDonald's on Yelp look at the
reviews one and a half one one and a
half one and a half one and a half it's
all one and a half one and a half one
why because you're spending 5 10 15 20
bucks right I said if you go to a
regular restaurant where the bill is
going to be 20 look at that one and a
half 1.3 I'm telling you what the hell
you want okay so so this [__]
want food apparently oh you want it to
be hot too so watch this this guy thinks
he needs hot food in his life so I said
if you go to a restaurant I'm telling
Dylan Antico this like I'm telling tan
this I said if you go to a restaurant
where the bill is not high but they give
you great service you got to take care
of them sorry
sorry so anyways we go to Seasons
52 I'm parking a car these guys going
it's not a nice restaurant it's a it's a
it's a the ticket is like where's that
that's Capital Grill yeah you're right
you're right it's it's I would say it's
a level below Capital Grill I would
actually put cap Capal girls and the way
I'm saying below is Bill the money
you're going to spend at Capital gr is
going to be two times the amount of
money you're going to spend at Season 52
oh wow two times two times yeah really
yeah so anyway we go to Susan Season
52 and I'm parking a car me and Dylan
are walking in I finally find them I
come inside and Jennifer's like bab we
just the waiter's name is
Michael and we're all watching this guy
and then the car everyone's talking
about we're going to experience what the
waiter's going to be like Michael like
hey how are you listen great to have you
guys here a what can I get you Mom what
would you like Dad what can I get you
this guy crushes it and I keep asking
him zero to 10 guys daddy this guy's
good he's not said nope one
time is that him right there that's him
right there so shout out to Michael the
food the bill bill comes at the end
Michael's been fantastic so we Bill him
we tip him
100% so I'm talking to the kids what do
you think we should tip him should we
tip him to 25% no we should tip him more
30% no how about we do 40% I said how
about we do 100% we're going to do 100%
I said but here's what we're going to do
we're going to do 100% and you're going
to walk up to him and you're going to
give him the check with the 100% tip and
tell them how we as a family the bed
David Family Values great service when
you go above and beyond and you did that
and we value that so much thank you for
doing this they walk up to him they give
him the tip
and they explain to him what it is this
grown man is listening to Tio giving him
the tip he's got emotion he's emotional
that's so awesome and we we take a
picture says you guys want to take a
picture I want to take I said no bro we
want to take a picture with you yeah
Michael Seasons 52 if you guys are in
the boka area you go there ask for him
an absolute stud of a freaking guy when
it comes down to service you were
phenomenal without even knowing we
didn't even tell them we're coming from
a bad experience oh really we I just
wanted the kids to know cuz sometimes
when that's the case you go above and
beyond I just wanted to see what he was
going to do he freaking crushed it so to
the people out there that are tipping 2%
the 2% that tips less than 15% the 2%
that tips nothing and the people that
tip 15% I will tell you some people
deserve zero tip their customer service
sucks they think you owe them something
but some people deserve 100% tip when
you meet somebody that's great show up
when you meet somebody that brings the
refill way before you even think about
it show up when you find somebody that
asks you doesn't use short words isn't
quick with you so we role played what's
the proper answer Dylan says so what
should the answer be I said let's role
play we're at the restaurant we're role
playing I said okay tell me what I asked
the waitress uh is there any way to
lower uh you know the temperature
because it's very cold here maybe turn
off the AC so Dylan says nope that's
that's not what you say theno says um
yes let me see what I can I'll get back
to you then sen says I don't know if we
can do anything but I'm going to find a
way then Dylan says you know the AC in
this corner control is the entire
restaurant but maybe we can seat you
somewhere else if you're okay that's
warmer I said that's all you have to say
that's it you don't have to say nope a
freaking nope you know the the PE is
just the shittiest nope like that's like
that's way worse than by the way by the
way do you see that kitchen straight
down the aisle behind him is that Jose
back no no no oh I thought you that
building Season 52 on on glage road yeah
at Business Center Drive in 1984 is when
that building was built the reason I
know that is I worked in that kitchen
the Tom be quiet the restaurant was
called the restaurant was called the
cork in Cleaver are you serious and it
was an original Steakhouse in bokeh and
when that was built brand new um what
you do for them Tom that that Tom that's
your old stomping ground the restaurant
yeah were you a cook were you a chef
were you a I was I was the chef's
assistant really you're Sue Chef [__]
well for a steakhouse yes I was a sue
chef but in a steakhouse and that's not
a complicated this this is do do you
know what the reputation was of this
place customers would leave super happy
after six years of Investigation they
realized the chef would put a little bit
of edible weed back in the days 80s into
the meal wow freaking nonstop
everybody's just happy and hungry well
back then there was no Twitter but Tom
was a big part of it canri good job Tom
I just want to add one thing it all kind
of makes sense because everything that
you're basically saying about your
family experience I've lived this with
all the restaurants that that I've dined
with you whether it was Yard House in
Dallas shout out to our boy Jason he
made the perfect Arnold Palmer love that
and then we would always eat at this
amazing French restaurant to yeah Pat is
a loyal guy if you treat him right he
will come back so good to and we go and
then I mean obviously here in Fort
Lauderdale our relationship with Casa
Kasa D'Angelo
that on your birthday when we were in um
Prime 112 in Miami and the waiter and he
gave back he paid half the bill like
value service and it all like sort of
coalesces with everything that's
happened with um uh will will uh how do
you say his will gadera unreasonable
Hospitality this is something you
ultimately realize you know I'm so glad
you reminded me of that if if any if
this clip goes and the restaurant cuz
remember that one time we did something
with the haircut 7 $2 haircut and then
that took off and people were calling
with your friend yeah Drew but if
anybody's in the restaurant business and
I'm just being honest with you if you
run a if you if you're the manager or if
you're a leader if you're a waiter that
wants to get paid better go read the
damn book unreasonable Hospitality yes
can you put this thing up everybody in
the service business must read
unreasonable Hospitality by freaking wil
can I can I be honest to God with you
Pat what what am I listening Ling to
right now on my on my phone look look at
my phone right there what what's what's
what am I listening to again for the
second timeon guess what guess what I
just heard I swear to God this is so
weird on the way in here I'm listening
to the audio book I forgot which
restaurant was I I think he was working
there Madison or it wasn't love I I I
might be wrong but I don't want to I
don't want to U Mis misstate it they're
eating at the restaurant and this family
that's visiting that's never seen snow
and it starts snowing outside guess what
the the owner does has somebody go bu y
snow they went and got sleds and they
went sledding they drove like half an
hour and they were they took the whole
family sledding he told that story can
you imagine going oh my God honey snow
and they took the whole kids that's
you'll never forget that memory I got to
give Vinnie a shout out yes for you know
that this guy he practices unre like he
made me my turkey plate over here after
the podcast got this guy he every after
every episode hey I got yogurt and fruit
you're very hospitable my mom made a
little cat cookie he's got his whole
thing but I'll say this cuz I was a
server in college right and no matter
what business you're in you're in the
people business and if you want to
practice unreasonable Hospitality you
want like any server that's working
their job and they're like What's Next
get into sales cuz server if you're a
server you have to deal with people you
have to take orders you have to
understand there's good days there's bad
days there's winning there's losing
there's so many different things that
you can do but at the end of the day
unreasonable Hospitality Lo loving
people and and and making people happy
bro when you do something for somebody
you give them something and they're
shocked and they're like it just makes
me feel good and I got that obviously
being a Syrian and my mom my mom just
shout out to your mom my mom s Lana
sweet Lana Lana we love you we miss you
Happy Thanksgiving mom wish you were
here Tom um we have a a story here
that's very interesting tomorrow is
Black Friday yeah today is turkey day
and this is you know we're we're all
into football today right yeah Tom you
have no idea how much I want to get in a
food fight with you right now I thought
maybe you're going to bust it out throw
some mashed potatoes at sorry Tom we we
can do that later baby D yeah that's
right so check this out Amazon is paying
$100 million for the broadcast rights to
one game and it's the Black Friday game
and Black Friday is on Friday and Sh in
the dark and by the way they've never
done that because the NFL never does a
Black Friday game for two reasons it was
a holiday people are going shopping and
the other thing you ready for this the
sports broadcasting Act of 1961 which is
federal law prohibited the NFL from
putting games on Fridays after 6 o'
because they were protecting college and
high school football yeah and they felt
that that was an important tradition for
America and they didn't want to let
televis commercialization football do it
well why did Amazon buy this check this
out Amazon paid $100 million for the
game and they checked in that they
weren't breaking the law if they
broadcast the game at 3:00 so it was
over by 6:00 so why are they putting
this game this game is going to be on
Amazon Prime but you you know who's
playing
though Miami Dolphins baby versus the
New York Jets Miami got the Dolphins by
the way by way you were you made an
amazing uh appearance with the and by
the way NFL usually destroys ratings on
Thanksgiving the average Thanksgiving
Day NFL game for the past four years has
been 33 million viewers the NB Christmas
Day game has never exceeded 5 million
viewers wow not comparable not
comparable so why did Amazon pay $100
million for one game step one they're
going to watch everybody can watch it on
Amazon for free it not not to Prime
people remember it used to be had to pay
for Amazon Prime to get Thursday Night
Football from Amazon that is it that it
now here comes here comes the crazy
thing they're charging advertisers
$880,000 for 30 seconds damn the normal
NFL game outside of playoffs is 440 ,000
double the price double the price and
they're doing get this audience-based
creative you're going to be watching it
on the Amazon channel right for free if
you are an Amazon Prime user you're
going to get these ads if you're not an
Amazon Prime user you're going to get
different ads that are tailored to you
Bose has signed up and there will be
three different ads Joe burrow will go
to the non Prime uh viewers and the
other Bose ads are there and while
you're watching the game check this out
that you can click on the screen and put
the product in your
shop without without turning away from
the game making some sales and personal
profit Port they will be they will be
retargeting they estimate that Amazon is
probably going to net net net do on this
they're probably not going to lose money
it's probably a $2 billion payday Tom
there it is so you're saying if the
camera Cuts I'm watching it on my phone
and it cuts to the cheerleaders and I'm
like damn I want that skirt I I could
just hit it um I you can hit it all
right I think some of the problem but
the point is Amazon is bringing
together football shopping Black Friday
and Technology pretty smart and families
Tom and and but look at this I mean I
just think we were talking about AI at
the beginning of the show look at all
the technology and AI That's that's
literally in the background here and
nice and Amazon goes knock knock knock
to NFL says can I pay 100,000 for a game
on Friday
they turned to each other and say heang
on a second Louis this is so easy yeah
yeah sure please wire that right over
we'll give you the Dolphins on on Black
Friday Tom real quick who do you like
dolphins or jets Dolphins uh a tough one
Dolphins Z wison is Zachy no he's
benched now he's gone to third string oh
the Miami the Miami looks third Stringer
now after the latest loss of the bills
you looked at me like I like shocked
anyway it's not just football today
turkey qu the NL sure who do you like on
the Dolphins by the way Tom Dolphins who
who do you like on the Dolphins like
what players I I've always had a lot of
respect for Tua I remember Tua playing
in the bowl games for Alabama and I
thought wow this guy is I felt he was a
little bit more special than just the
normal you know run option quarterback
you going somewhere with this or I just
want to see him and I've also I've also
I've been a fan of cheetah since he was
in Kansas City K Hill yeah yeah there
you go Tom I'm thinking he he's about to
do
okay Tom killed that
segment fantastic guys this is awesome
okay well listen Gang This was great we
were uh uh debating whether to do this
or not uh I didn't want to do it but
Adam said no we have to I can't believe
and he yelled at you he and he pointed I
want to wake up at 6: a.m. on
Thanksgiving and podcast then then
listen after a lot of uh convincing we
finally agreed to do it enjoy the
Thanksgiving I'll give you final
thoughts here to be thinking about uh
one of the hardest things to do is to be
grateful and what I mean by that is a
lot of people have an easy time not
being grateful they're typically wanting
to feel more entitled and it's it's a
the people that I've met that I've
continuously won who are typically the
happiest and enjoy life the most for
whatever reason are the most grateful
people in the world I don't know why
they're just more grateful people want
to work with grateful people people want
to help grateful people people want to
go above and beyond for grateful people
there's there's magic in having
gratitude and sometimes we are forced to
have a day of year to sit there and be
grateful for different things that has
happened over the years to you I got a
long list of stuff I feel I'm like the
luckiest man alive but I just want to
tell you I'm sure I speak on behalf of
everybody here with the Cru well we are
grateful for you I personally can say
I'm grateful for those of you that used
to watch 2 minutes with Pat with my pink
socks where back in the days it would I
when I watch 2 minutes with Pat right
now I I honestly I'm like somebody get
rid of these videos but we have to leave
them there to remind us how bad we once
used to be but for those of you that
have been with us for for many years
anybody that's supported the brand
anybody that's ever shared a clip that's
liked the clip that's commented on a
clip that's taken a time to watch it
with us and you stop by and we talk to
each other we have you know a unique
Bond the value tment in the pbd podcast
Community has a very very unique Bond
the entire team here Rob you've done a
great job this past year I'm proud of
Rob the team out there the guys that are
cutting you guys are working your tail
off this whole thing was put together by
uh Kelly K Kelly's amazing what she's
done Brandon you know where you are
Brandon's right now he's he's uh I see
he's flying somewhere Egypt or or do you
call it connectic he's he in Connecticut
he's in Connecticut right now on the
border of Connecticut he's over there
doing what he's doing but to to the
entire crew here that's done what
they've done with VT and pbd podcast all
year long you guys are fantastic future
looks bright excited about where we're
going to go next and to everybody else
have a great weekend we will do this
again next week take care everybody bye-
bye
bye-bye